so desires of the heart how did you get
the job to direct the film well it's
funny I was actually in Los Angeles for
the two weeks prior to my interview for
desires of the heart and the production
manager of the film called me because I
had known him vaguely that the director
who was supposed to make the film had
been hospitalized in India for drinking
a handle of whiskey a day and smoking
four packs of cigarettes a day and his
health was in dire shape which
understandably so and so I was here in
Los Angeles having meetings with some
pretty fantastic companies and they kept
calling me from georgia and i said no i
can't can't come air view for this and
can't come do this can't come do this
and then finally the producer calls me
and says well i really want to meet with
you and i will come back to Georgia when
you return from Los Angeles because at
the time i was living in Georgia and so
I get there and she flies down from New
York where she was living and we have
like this 18-hour over two day marathon
meeting where we talk about the
screenplay talk about the movie talk
about all these different things and at
the end of these two days I'm exhausted
because we had gone through everything
and I said well you know if you however
you choose to hire a director for this
film I wish you best of luck and she
said at the end of it well I've decided
I want you to direct it after our two
days and that's how I got involved with
the film simply because I happen to know
the production manager that thought my
work was suitable for the picture
you